Gentlemen, the floor is all yours.
>> Thanks. Uh, so I want to, if we can,
let's talk about 1094 really quick. Uh,
well, I wanted to clarify. I did not say
that Iban Abbas said that it's a
guardian. I said he said that it's
trustworthy, not I said others say that
it's a guardian. And then the word
>> where does where do you get that?
>> The the word guardian. The word Muhammad
literally means guardian. If you go to
the corpus, it pulls up and it
translates as guardian. And so
>> I thought you said IB said that.
>> No, I said Iban Abbas says trustworthy.
>> Where where does he say that?
>> You'll find that in certain tops. So if
I were to
>> which one
>> I looked at Iben Kafir and Iben Cafir is
one of the major depers. It didn't say
guardian or trustworthy.
>> I didn't say Iba says that.
>> So which one?
>> I'm saying Iban Abbasa. One of the
opinions of Ibnas about uh Muhammad is
trustworthy. Uh
>> Iban Abbas is an exedite but he doesn't
have like an a tapsier that we can open
up like a book. Iban Kafir is the comp
is the tapier that will record the
opinion of Iban Abbas and other
scholars. So which are you talking
about? Are you talking about
are you talk which like which has this
opinion of Abas?
>> Are you saying that in in the he says
that Abbas says that it's a judge over
the previous scriptures? Yeah.
>> Can we see that really quick?
>> Uh, just go to Iban Cafir online. You
can find the translation. Just I'm not
sure if it's in the a bridged version,
but there is a translation of the verse
and it'll it'll bring up the different
it's like a big block of text and just
control find.
All right, here it is. So, so it says
here
um so and Mahan over it means entrusted
over it. According to Sophia and I'm
going just skip down to where they
mentioned Abas. Okay. Uh it says um
Sufan Aari who narrated it from Abu Alak
from Tamini from Iban Abbas. Ali bin Abi
Talha reported that Iban Abbas said
Muayan is the trustworthy.
>> Yeah. So keep reading. Keep reading. So
that's what it Okay. Um so that's
Abbas's opinion. Then it says Allah says
that the Quran is trustworthy over every
divine book that preceded it. This was
reported from
so now they're talking about other
says that is trustworth.
>> Keep going. Keep going. Ai
do you see that?
>> Okay. Yeah I see
>> narrated from Abbas
means
>> all right. So Alfafi says that Abbas
said that Muhammad means dominant over
the previous scriptures. These meanings
are similar as the word Muhammad
includes them all. But consequently the
Quran is trustworthy, a witness dominant
over every scripture that preceded it.
So it looks like we both were right
about what Abas is saying, right? I
wasn't wrong. Uh the full context shows
that it's a comprehensive meaning. So
it's but the ultimate point is that the
Abbas thinks the Quran is dominating is
judging over the previous scripture. Not
judging. It doesn't say anything about
judging the previous scripture. Just
that as dominant it's the final
revelation. I can understand him
thinking that it's dominant in that way
because it's the final revelation but
not he doesn't say judging over the
previous scripture.
The Arabic is
yes.
Well, haken can also mean judge. Like it
it can judge open. Yeah.
>> I I I I disagree.
>> The Arabic. You disagree with the
Arabic. You disagree. You know, you know
Arabic.
>> I don't think that's what the
>> We're going to get in Arabic debate.
>> It doesn't it doesn't mean that in
Arabic. That's the point.
>> Dominant.
>> No, the the word here. Yeah. It means
dominant just like they said. He doesn't
say judge.
>> So, but if but this is this is my point.
If you're saying that uh that the that
the Quran never says for the previous
scriptures to be used as a judge over
the Quran in 1094
I I would like I would like us to have a
discussion about that when it tells
Muhammad you agree that it's talking to
Muhammad if he had a doubt about what
the Quran is telling him. Is that
correct?
>> Say that again
>> in 1094. Do you agree that Allah is
addressing Muhammad if he has doubts
about what Allah's telling him in the
Quran?
Yeah, the verse I mean that literally
that's what the verse says. Okay. It's
not about what the what the Quran says.
Let's read it.
>> It is. It says what if you are in doubt
about what that which we have revealed
to you. What's being revealed to
Muhammad?
>> Okay. Yeah. So if you're in doubt about
that which we have revealed to you, then
ask those who have been reading the
scripture before you.
>> Okay. So what's that supposed to do for
Muhammad? How's that supposed to help
him?
>> It's supposed to for him to see. We can
go to the taps of this as well. The taps
says that if you are in doubt like about
your path as a prophet that you face
tribulations that you have companions
die that you're facing this kind of
opposition from the people that this is
also what previous prophets have
experienced
>> right and my question to you is where
does this verse say that oh Muhammad
judge your message judge your the the
Quran according to the previous
scriptures in the sense of evaluate if
it's true like the the message of the
monotheism of the Quran
the uh laws of the Quran, judge all of
that according to the previous
scriptures. Where where do you find that
in the verse?
>> Are are you well, it says if you're
doubting that which we have revealed to
you. What was revealed to him is the
Quran. Correct?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, if he's doubting the Quran,
Allah tells him what to do if he doubts
the Quran. Go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you. So,
you're using the Quran, the previous
scriptures to verify and judge the Quran
to make sure it's in place. That's why I
asked where
>> where does it say everything where does
it say everything in the scriptures
everything in the scriptures is true
that's why I asked you I'm getting to
that we trust me I'm getting to that
first I'm dealing with what's the
authority what's the judge because you
your argument was that the Quran never
tells you tells us to use the previous
scriptures as a judge over the Quran so
I'm dealing with this point first okay
now coming here if Muhammad is in doubt
about the Quran he's supposed to go ask
those who've been reading the scripture
before him.
How will that help his doubt in the
Quran?
>> I explained that. I told you how it how
it helps to see the previous stories of
the prophets.
>> Got it.
>> To see to read to read the stories of uh
Moses or Jesus or to see those stories.
Yeah. Okay. That No. So my question now
my question is where does the scripture
>> this is not this is not a interrogation.
I'm asking you a question. You asked me
a question and I'm asking you a
question. building a
>> get to the part get to the part or the
point where the verse says everything in
the previous scriptures is true.
>> Well, I I I'll get
>> and to judge Islam to judge Islam as a
whole according to the scripture.
>> Daniel, I I promise you I will get
there. I'm building up to that. That's
that's why I'm asking you the question.
I'm not asking you as an interrogation.
I'm trying to build a point here. Okay?
And and vice versa. I'll let you of
course I'll let you do the same thing.
So, so he's supposed to, it helps him by
being able to go back and check the
stories of the previous prophets to to
see that what's going on with him and
what the Quran is saying is in line with
the previous prophets. Is that correct?
You could say that. All right. So if
Muhammad sees that he's in line with the
pre stories of the previous prophets and
what happens to them and their journeys
and what the Quran is saying, then he'll
have no reason to doubt what the Quran
is saying, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. That means the opposite is true.
that if he checks and he sees that this
doesn't match the stories of the
prophets and what the Quran is saying is
not in line with the stories of the
prophets then Muhammad would have a good
reason to doubt what the Quran is saying
and know the Quran is false right
>> if that were the case
>> so if that's the case what according to
this verse is the judge on whether or
not the Quran is true is it the Quran
itself or is to the previous scriptures
in this case.
>> No, you're equivocating like this is
>> the the the I'll explain like the the
Bible contains evidence supporting
Islam. The Bible contains evidence
supporting like the prophet's message,
the prophet's life. That that's
evidence. That doesn't mean the Bible is
the final criterion. The that nowhere in
this verse again I ask you where does it
say judge Islam according to the
scripture. It's saying if you have doubt
you'll you'll find evidence. If you have
doubt then ask those who have been
reading scriptures.
>> Like if I have a doubt about something
like if I have a doubt for example about
like you live in Georgia right? You're
living in the on the east coast right?
>> Yeah.
>> If I have a question or I have a doubt
about well you know what's the um GDP of
Georgia for example. I have a doubt
about it. I can ask you about it. I can
say ask those who have been in this
country or in the state in Georgia. Ask
them does that mean that I think that
you everything that you say about
Georgia is correct and everything that
you say about everything in in the in
life is correct just because I'm asking
you just because I'm asking you for
evidence or information because I have a
doubt about Georgia. You're in Georgia.
I'm going to ask you about it. That
doesn't because you have some
information that could help me.
That doesn't mean that you're the judge
over everything that happens in Georgia.
You're the judge of everything that
happens in life.
>> I got you. So you qualified it. I like
your example with this qualification.
Let me grant you this. Right. So
pertaining to the facts about Georgia,
what's the authority on the facts about
Georgia? Is it you or is it me?
>> I don't have to uh be committal to you
being the authority.
>> When you said that,
>> I just say that you have evidence. Where
in the verse does it say the previous
scripture is the authority? I keep
asking you these questions. You don't
answer. You don't answer the question.
>> No. Where? Okay. So, where where does
the where in the verse says the
scripture is the authority? Where?
>> Let me just say it because I believe
that this is where this
>> say no answer. No answer. Where in the
verse does it say the scripture is the
authority?
>> Can I talk? You're kind of interrupting
me right now.
>> You're not answering my question. I
asked answered your question. You don't
answer my question.
>> I do need to All right, let's hear from
Avery.
>> I appreciate it. Yeah, it's all it's all
good, man. No need for you. We're good
here, dog. So, uh I I gave you this
verse here. And the reason why I gave
you this verse and you're having trouble
with it because you know it says exactly
what we're saying. You know where this
is going. You already acknowledge
Daniel. You already acknowledged that if
Muhammad's doubting what the Quran is
telling him, then to help his doubts, he
can find evidence of the Quran from the
previous scripture and that would remove
any doubts. he'll know that the Quran is
true. You also acknowledged that if he
checks and it's not in line with the
previous scriptures, the stories of the
prophets, then he'll know that the Quran
is not telling the truth and he'll have
good reason to doubt. So based on that,
which is why you didn't answer this
question because you know the problem
here. Based on that, we see what the
authority is. I'm trying to help you see
it. Based on that, if the Quran is in
line with the previous scripture,
Muhammad will know it's true. If the
Quran is not in line with the previous
scripture, then Muhammad will know it's
false.
>> This is the judge and authority based on
that text and based on that framework on
the truthfulness of the Quran. What's
the what's the judge here? Let me So now
let me explain it slowly so you can
understand Avery. If the Quran is saying
that you consult the previous scripture
and you will have evidence and it will
help with a doubt that does not say that
that scripture is the authority and that
and the verse does not say that the only
evidence is coming from the previous
scripture. I didn't say this is yes you
implied it because if the Bible if let
me finish now if the Bible is the
authority that means there's no other
evidence or there's no other authority
that can confirm the doubts or or can
provide evidence for the doubts if the
Bible if the previous scripture is the
authority but there is other authorities
there is the authority of God Almighty
the one who's revealing it there is the
authority of other evidence other ayat
other signs and evidences not just not
just the previous script
plenty. Yeah. The verses of the Quran
say to look to the heavens and the earth
to look to the Yes, it does. To to see
signs yet.
No, no, don't interrupt. See, I I don't
interrupt you. You told me you told me
you told me to be quiet, right?
>> We'll give Daniel a chance to quick wrap
up and then we'll come back to you,
Avery.
So as I mentioned the verse nowhere does
it say that the scripture is the
authority over the Quran or over the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
the analogy that I gave that you just
ignored is that if I ask you Avery as a
resident of Georgia tell me about what's
the GDP in Georgia that doesn't mean I'm
making you the authority over all facts
of Georgia. I just can if I have a doubt
about it I can ask you I can consult
with you and that doesn't make you the
authority. It doesn't mean that you're
the only evidence. You're the ultimate
arbiter of what is true or not. Do you
do you understand that analogy, Avery?
>> Yeah. So, here's the here's the problem.
Uh you won't answer the question. And
the reason why you won't answer the
question, Daniel, is because you see the
problem. You don't even know it, but you
just admitted that the Bible, the
previous scripture, is the authority on
which Muhammad is to judge whether or
not the Quran is telling him the truth
or not. Matter of fact, going even
further, even with your example, you're
demonstrating what the evidence is. Now,
you now you said
>> my example, the analogy. Tell me
give everybody a chance.
>> It's okay. So, let me just let me just
lend this. You said, well, there's other
evidences that he can go to. Is that
what the verse says? Show show. Look, do
me this favor.
>> This is the autism that we're talking
about. This is the you want to answer
the question any
>> chance otherwise you got to go to
two-minute segments.
>> The Quran is very clear here. If you are
in doubt, Muhammad, do this. Go to the
people who've been reading the scripture
before you. Show me anywhere in the
Quran where ma where where Allah tells
Muhammad, if you're in doubt about that
which we have revealed to you, do
something else.
>> Yeah, I can pull up you some verses. Go
ahead. I'm waiting.
No, but while I'm pointing that out or
while I'm pulling that up, can you
explain to me the variant the biggest
variance between the
>> why?
You mentioned it in your response. Why
can't you give me an answer? The reason
why I mentioned variances in the reason
why I mentioned variances in my response
is because you brought up variances to
equal corruption. So, I'm showing you
how you're you're shooting yourself in
the foot by saying because there there's
textual variances that that equals
corruption and the Quran is calling that
out. Well, if that's equals corruption,
then the Quran's corrupted because it
has textual variances. It's not about
how big the variances are and how many
are there are. Let's compare. It's not
about that. That's irrelevant. The fact
that the Quran has variances in its text
means that it's corrupted according to
your standard.
No, the v the variance in the Bible
between the manuscripts are so vast like
there are entire sections that are added
to the Gospel of Mark for example ending
of the Gospel of Mark. Where is the
analog of that in the Quran? Is there an
entire chapter ending of the Quran
that's been added that's in one versus
another?
>> Brother,
so so the challenge was so the challenge
Yeah. Hey, I let you talk. I let you
talk. So the ch
let me clarify the question so you
understand.
>> Give me an example that is analogous
>> to the biblical variance where there is
a vast difference in meaning that
actually changes or a difference in
variant that changes the meaning. Give
me one example. You claim that there are
some. So give me one example. That's it.
>> Sure. I got you. In H's Quran in chapter
37:12 it says that Allah speaking to
Muhammad. He's the speaker in the
context. Allah says to Muhammad, "You
wonder why they mocked."
You wonder why they mock. In the um in
the Quran and Alkasai Quran, it says
two, "I wonder why they mock." Allah
saying that he wonders. Would you would
you agree with me that there's a big
difference between Allah doing something
and Muhammad doing something?
>> No.
>> Okay. I you know, maybe
>> that's not a big difference. Like the
difference the differences in the Quran
here. Is that similar to the difference
when it comes to the ending of Mark? An
entire ending of a of the gospel of Mark
being added
>> an entire going an entire ending of a
gospel and the earliest church fathers
had no clue about this ending. It wasn't
and it's not found in the earliest Greek
manuscripts of the gospel of Mark. The
entire ending was added
>> and that ending is significant. Why?
Because it's it's about the resurrection
of Jesus. has great theological
significance or let's talk about the uh
variations between
>> can you find the verse
uh in Mark?
>> No. Can you find the verse that tells
Muhammad if he's in doubt about what
Allah has revealed to him do something
else because that's what you're supposed
to
>> Oh yeah yeah yeah. I'll give you
examples of that. You want to know
>> on top of that? Do you agree?
>> What about here? Let me ask your
question. You want you wanted
>> I know but just give me a second. Do you
also agree that there's a difference
that meaning changes between Muhammad
doing something and Allah doing
something? That that's a meaning change?
What is the theological significance of
that? Explain it to me.
>> No. No. Do Do you agree that
>> I don't I don't understand. Yeah. I I
acknowledge. No. No. See, you don't you
misunderstand me, Avery.
>> I acknowledge that there are differences
between the That changes the meaning.
Yes. That changes the meaning. So for
example,
they did versus you all did for example
>> or do sorry you you th those kinds of
differences exist between the obviously
any like uh 10year-old madrasa student
who's memorizing the knows that there
are differences in the and yes it's a
technical difference in the meaning but
my my uh challenge to you was more
specific give me a difference in meaning
that is theologically significant that
is equivalent to the type of theological
significance of an entire ending of a
gospel about the resurrection and or the
uh paricop adultery the uh the passages
in John about do not he who without sin
should cast the first stone basically
erasing the uh Mosaic law when it comes
to stoning adulterers in this passage
this is erasing thing uh in John it's
erasing the Mosaic law the punishment
for adultery for sexual crimes that is
extremely significant theologically
because it's about the applicability of
the Mosaic law uh and there's nothing
like that in the Quran if you find me a
passage in the Quran where there's a
verse because in one in one variant it
says that yeah don't apply the Sharia
like don't don't lash the fornicator
like find me that would be an analog
that would be something comparable
in the Quran. All you can say is
>> yes, please give me an example like
that.
>> So, no. So, the reason why I'm not going
to waste my time chasing that rabbit
trail is because that's a vocal shift.
That's not just the first what you what
you challenged me on to do immediately.
You challenged me to show you a a change
in the meaning when it comes to the
textual variances. And I did that. And
it's and it's actually if you're trying
to say that it's not significant that
Allah is the one that is wondering and
Muhammad is the one that's wondering.
Whichever one is wondering, whoever's
the one that's surprising, you're saying
that it's not that big of a difference
between Allah and your prophet, just a
mere man. That's not a theological
difference. I
>> what what aspect of theology does it
affect?
>> Just just one second, please. Just one
second, please. I If you want to say
that, that's that's fine. You you can
have your position if you want to do
look I I'll I'll do this right now. We
and we got each other's context now. I
will be open to having a debate with you
on textual variances and if there are
meaningful differences, theological
differences, textual diff contextual
differences in the kara in the karat. I
will be glad to have a debate with you
on that. But right now that's not the
debate. Daniel, let's
>> don't tell me what the debate is. The
debate is about the
of the previous scriptures. So the
variance of the Bible is extremely
relevant to this debate. I'm sorry
you're not prepared to have that debate,
but we are talking about the variance
and the distortion and the corruption of
the Bible. That's literally what the
Islamic dilemma is about.
>> I guess the corrupted scripture.
>> No, no, because again I said very
clearly, show me the biggest difference
in meaning. That was the challenge. Show
me the biggest
>> I said the Quran is confirming corrupted
scripture. So, so what so what is the
theological significance of uh the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam being
surprised or
>> that doesn't matter.
>> It does. It does because I give I'm
giving you the depth of differences
between the manuscript varants in the in
the Bible when it comes to the Old
Testament when it comes to the New
Testament. I'm giving you these major
differences and deviences because we're
talking about corruption of the Bible.
You can't cope with it. You can't handle
it.
>> You know what? You know what? You you
you you're right, Daniel. You got it.
There's there's according to you there.
According to you, Daniel, there's major
differences and and variations in the
Bible. And the Bible is corrupted
because of that. Guess what, Daniel?
>> Thank you.
>> That means that the Quran is confirming
a corrupted book. And therefore, the
Quran is false. You're
>> nowhere nowhere does the Quran confirm
the Bible as fully true.
>> Let me land. I know. You got to let me
land. So according to the position that
you're positing, you're still in the pot
of the Islamic dilemma. You're not out
of it because now you're just on the
side that says, "Well, the the Bible's
corrupted." Okay, cool. The Quran is
confirming corrupted scripture. Simple.
Matter of fact, let me ask you this.
When when did these variances happen?
Did these variances these corruptions
did these meaningful variances happen um
before Muhammad's time or after
Muhammad's time? What do you think?
>> Before and after. It's still happening
to this day. And why do you say like
these supposed corruptions? Like it's a
fact. Like are you denying it? Are you
denying Are you denying that there are
variants of the Bible? Yes or no?
>> Okay. So, no. No. I'm not I'm not
denying that there's textual variants.
>> Thank you. Thank you. You're not denying
the the biblical corruption.
>> You don't deny the Quranic textual
variances.
>> So So you believe in you believe in
biblical corruption, but the Quran you
don't have the Quran recognized.
>> No, that's your position. You say
variances are corruption, which is why
the Quran's corrupted. So, the variance
of the Bible, how do you explain that?
How is that not corruption? You've been
asking questions. You've been
interrogating me. But whenever I ask you
questions,
>> gentlemen, just one second. Okay,
>> just hold on one sec. All right, just
take a deep breath. Okay,
so Daniel, I think you're saying, "Hey,
Avery, you've asked me questions. I want
to ask you some questions." Is that what
you're saying?
>> He's asked me. He's been dealing with
this question. I I maybe I didn't start
that sentence with Daniel. If I said
Avery, sorry. Like I actually like I'm
not being facitious. I'm so tired. I
can't tell. Um but Daniel, I think you
said you just want to ask some
questions. And
um Avery, uh you're you're kind of like,
"Hey, Daniel, you're interrupting me."
So, I get where both of you are coming
from,
but um
>> are there any time? We're fine. I just
>> This is going to happen. We just
>> Yeah, we'll try to limit it. We'll try
to limit it.
So, Avery, here's a simple question has
to do with my opening statement. Do you
believe in biblical biblical inherency?
>> Are you going to get the verse?
>> Oh, you you want that? Okay.
>> Yes. Do you think about you think about
biblical inherency as I read this verse?
>> Says
21:7. And we did not send before you
except men to whom we revealed. So ask
the people of knowledge if you do not
know. Whoa.
>> Yeah. So that's 217. Whoa. Blew your
mind, right? And then uh 16:43. And we
did not send before you except men to
whom we revealed our message. So ask the
people of knowledge if you do not know.
That's
>> exactly what is that word? What does
that mean?
>> It's people of knowledge, people of
remembrance. Translated
>> the reminder. Who are they? Who are the
people of the reminder that Muhammad if
if you don't know where are they
supposed to go to the people of the
reminder? Who are they?
>> People of knowledge.
>> Who are they?
>> People of knowledge. People of
knowledge. It could it could it could be
Christians. Yeah, it could be
Christians.
>> Thank you so much. But this is not a go.
This is my point is the point that I'm
bringing you.
See, you're you're asking me questions
and you don't let me finish the point.
>> No, Daniel, you don't let me land. I was
on your point, bro.
>> Okay, go ahead. Go ahead, Daniel. We'll
give you a chance to wrap up.
>> So, you asked me what other verses
exist. You challenged me and you said
what other verses exist where the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
being told to ask others. And your point
was that there's no your implication was
that there are no other verses. So I
find these verses where the prophet
sallallaihi wasallam is supposed to ask
not the scripture but ask others ask
people of
um and again that's as a reference point
it's a data point in order to uh answer
a question not that that those people
are the ultimate authority. So for
example, if the if the prophet sallall
alaihi wasallam or someone had a doubt
about whether alcohol is prohibit
prohibited, do they go would they have
to go to the Bible and see okay is
alcohol prohibited and then based off
off of that take whatever the Bible
says. Is that's what is that what you
believe in? Can I respond? Yep. Okay.
Matter of fact, let me just answer you
fully. Uh yes, I do I do believe that.
Now let me respond in full. Daniel, you
went to verses that literally says to
come to us if you don't know. Come to
us. You're literally proving my point
that the verifier of the Quran, the
determining truth of the Quran is us.
You got to come to us. Even when you
talk about that's why I had you say what
the ver what the word is in in the
Arabic is the people of the reminder.
That's us. That's our book. So you need
to come to us if you do not know. Now by
the way my question was not show me
where where else in the Quran Muhammad
says to ask or Muhammad is told to ask
someone. I didn't say that. My my
question my my challenge to you was is
show me in the Quran where if you don't
know or if you are in doubt about what
the Quran is saying to do something else
other than come to us. That's what I
challenged you on. So you gave me two
other verses that proved my point that
we are the judge. Our scripture is the
judge of the Quran. And if the Quran is
out of line with it, then guess what?
The Quran is false. So you gave now we
got three of them. 2117, 1643, and
chapter 10 94 that says use the Bible as
the judge of the Quran.
>> So this is just you're multiplying the
autism here. Where in any of these
verses? Where in any of these verses
does it say that the the scripture is
the final author? The previous
scriptures are the final authority are
the only authority where again you keep
uh failing to acknowledge the uh point
that I'm making.
>> Can you Here's a question for you Avery.
If I ask you something about anything
that you might have more knowledge than
me about, does that mean that you're in
authority over every every piece of
knowledge?
>> No. No.
>> No. Okay. So, if I ask you even about
something that you might have more
knowledge than me about and I ask you,
the fact that I'm asking you does not in
any way imply that you are an authority
over that subject
>> just because you might have more
knowledge. So how is it the case that
when the when the Quran is saying if you
are in doubt oh Muhammad about that
which was revealed then ask those who
have been reading the scripture those
who have or those who are for example in
the other verses what why does that mean
why are you extrapolating and saying
that that means that the scriptures are
the judge and the authority over all of
Islam
>> explain how that how that's different
than the example of me asking you about
Georgia.
>> I got you. So, so I like your example
and that's a fair question. So, Daniel,
look, I'm going to go with your analogy.
Now, follow me, okay?
>> If um let's say that you're asking me
about a subject, right? You're uh I'm
telling you about a subject and um
you're asking me about this subject and
when you ask me something, I say, "You
know what? If you're doubting what I'm
saying, if you if you're doubting what
I'm saying or you don't know, then go to
this person." Let's say go to person go
to I don't know Jeremiah right go to
Jere if you if you're doubting what I'm
saying go to Jeremiah.
So would you agree that that I am
implying that Jeremiah is an authority
on what I'm saying that when you go to
Jeremiah you can go and he's going to
say the same thing I'm saying be in line
with it and you'll know that you can
trust what I said about this subject or
if he says something different you'll
know that I'm false about the subject.
So what do you mean by authority?
>> That when I say if you're doubting what
I'm saying, you can go to Jeremiah.
If you're doubting what I'm saying, go
to Jeremiah. So if you go to Jeremiah,
I'm implying that he's the authority of
what I'm telling you about and he can
confirm for you and be in line with what
I'm saying so you can know that you can
trust me. Right.
>> Okay. Now I understand where the
misunderstanding is. you're equivocating
on the word authority. Cuz if I say that
yes, I'm an authority. That can mean two
things. I'm an authority on um Texas,
for example, because I live in Texas.
That can mean I just I have a lot of
information about Texas. I'm
knowledgeable about it and people can
ask me. That's one idea of authority.
Another idea of authority is I am the
authority. No one can disagree with me.
No one can have a different opinion. I
am the absolute authority and anyone who
is going to dis differ from me is going
to be uh known to be completely wrong.
So you see there's two different uh uh
connotations of authority and you're
equivocating between those two. That's
your problem. So I acknowledge so the
questions I answered when you were
asking me those questions. I am
understanding authority as yeah the
scripture has information true
information about the prophets and so it
is an authority in that sense in the
sense that it has information but that
doesn't mean your connotation of
authority authority in the sense of the
final arbiter the decider the ultimate
judge that's the connotation that I
reject and it's not in the actual verses
that you're citing
>> okay so walk with me on this so if if I
tell you if you're doubting what I'm
saying, Daniel, you can go ask Jeremiah.
I'm sending you to Jeremiah and he's
going to be the authority on whether or
not you can trust me. Correct?
Yes. So, if Jeremiah says anything
different from me, then that means I'm
not trustworthy, right?
I It depends. It depends on what else I
know about you. It depends on other
factors
>> on this subject, brother. No, look, I'm
being very specific on this specific
subject. I'm saying, look, if you're
doubting what I'm saying regarding this,
then you can go ask Jeremiah.
So, when you ask Jeremiah, if he says,
if what he says is in line with what I
say, you'll know that you can trust what
I said. If what he says is different
from what I said, then you can't trust
what I say, right? Because I sent you to
him as the authority to as trust, right?
It's a data point. It's a data point,
but there could be other data points.
But like if I if if I say like if a
Buddhist comes to me and says, "I don't
believe in Moses." Or a Buddhist comes
to you and says, "Hey, Avery, I don't
believe in Moses." And then you say,
"Well, if you don't know much about
Moses, go ask the Jews." The Jews
consider him the greatest prophet. Go
ask the Jews. Does that mean the Jews
are the authority on the end all beall
of Moses and the prophets and God?
That's what that would mean? Yes. It
would mean that they're the authority
because they have the Torah in which
they have the story of Moses in. That's
where it's at. So if you when you when
you when you're saying, "Hey man, if
you're doubting what I'm saying, then
you can go ask these people, right?"
>> So So the Jews So the Jews would be the
authority on Moses, on God, because
Moses is a prophet of God. Ba based on
that statement, Daniel, based on that
statement, if you say, "Hey, if you're
telling stories about Moses and you say,
"Hey, if you're doubting what I'm
saying, you can go ask the Jews who have
the Torah." So, you're pointing to the
Jews as the Torah as the authority of
what I'm telling you. And so, if what
I'm telling you doesn't match what the
Jews have in the Torah, then what I'm
telling you is false. If it matches,
then what I'm telling you is true. But
the the Jews will say that Moses is the
prophet of God, not the prophet who was
sent by a trinity.
>> So they will they will disagree. They
will the Jews will disagree on your
theology.
>> Depends on the Jews. But
>> yeah, it depends. Yeah. Exactly. It
depends. Exactly what I was what I'm
telling you. It depends. The context
matters.
>> Yeah. But what what I'm saying is Daniel
is that I'm not talking about like going
into actual the theological view of the
Jews. I'm talking about just the
statement. I'm talking about the
statement. What does the statement What
does the statement imply? The statement
implies
>> it's ambiguous. It's ambiguous. That's
the whole point. Yeah, it is
>> brother.
>> Okay. Because I can if someone
>> Exactly. In the example that I gave you,
if someone comes to me and says, I have
a question about this and I can tell
them, hey, go ask someone else. This
person is an authority on that subject.
That's ambiguous. Do I mean that's he's
an authority in the fact that he has
more knowledge?
He has more knowledge. But that doesn't
mean he's the authority in the sense
that whatever he says is the end all
beall of everything on every on every
religious matter. The Quran is tell the
Quran is saying consult.
It's saying consult the previous
scriptures. Not in the sense that the
previous scriptures are the authority on
all religious matters. Like how how are
you not getting this? So let's let's
let's be clear on this. Let me ask you
this. What what does doubt mean? What do
you what do you how do you what do you
interpret doubt to me? Doubt can mean
like you don't have some knowledge.
You're lacking in knowledge
>> of the truth of a thing, right? Of the
truth of a subject, right?
>> The truth of Yeah. a particular subject,
>> right? So, you don't know about the
truth of a subject. You might be right.
You're you're in the middle. You don't
know. Right. Okay. So, if I tell you,
hey, in order to clear up your doubts
about this subject, you can go there.
What am I saying when I point you to
some something or someone
as a way to clear up the doubts? Meaning
this is a way that you can get the truth
of this subject. Go here. Am I saying
that this is an authority
for the thousandth time? Avery, what
connotation of authority? If you mean
someone who has knowledge, can provide
data, can provide evidence,
>> that they have the that they have the
truth, that they have the truth,
>> they have they have truth about one
certain subject, not necessarily the
truth about everything in the world, not
the truth about every single issue and
they're the ultimate judge,
>> okay, of that particular
>> fair. Okay. If that's if you can
understand that as being a possible
meaning, then the verse that you're
citing means that it means that the
scripture is a data point. It has some
truth, but it's not the ultimate arbiter
of truth of of everything you're saying,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, let me go with you even though
I don't agree, but I can grant this
position.
>> I don't want the entire look, I don't
want the entire uh open dialogue to just
be on this one verse. So you're
dominating the time like this is the
subject that you started with at 30
minutes ago. So I want to move on to
another subject.
>> All right. Can I can I say one last
thing on it then?
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay. And I I want your engagement on
this this last thing and then we can go
off.
>> So with that being said, I can grant for
the sake of the argument that this is
pertaining to a limited subject. Let's
say particularly the stories of the
prophets because in the context it talks
about Noah and Moses and the Exodus and
the Egyptians and Pharaoh and stuff like
that. All that leading up and then boom
we get 1094. If you're doubting what we
have revealed to you, I would say
pertaining to those things we just to
just said then go and ask those who've
been read reading the scripture for you.
Okay, cool. So if Muhammad's doubting,
if he doesn't have the truth, if he's
questioning the truth of what the Quran
is saying pertaining specifically to the
stories of the prophets, the Quran says,
"Go ask those who've been reading the
scripture before you. The truth has come
to you from your Lord. So don't doubt."
So according to this verse, the data
point of truth regarding this subject
are the peop the people who read in the
scripture before you, right? The
previous scriptures. That's the data
point of the truth of this subject,
right?
>> Yes. They have a data point on this
subject. Yes.
>> Awesome. So, with that being said, if
the Quran is not in line with that data
point of truth, then therefore the Quran
would be false. Correct?
>> No. Depends on other contextual other
data.
>> Other data.
So, this is I don't know what's so
funny, but let's I'm thinking that we've
got we've had hit the
>> limit on this point because we've burned
through 30 minutes of our open dialogue.
So, again, I'll ask you,
>> do you believe in biblical inherency?
>> The Quran does. It doesn't matter what I
believe.
>> Well, I'm asking you does do you believe
in biblical inherency?
>> My belief is is irrelevant to this
debate, dude.
>> Oh, I'm just wondering like is that a
secret? Like, you can't reveal that?
Yeah, it's a secret in this debate on
whether I believe. I'll tell I'll tell
you what.
>> Okay. I'm an original. It's I'm an
original Quran only Christian. So
because
>> So there are some Christians
>> because the Quran affirms biblical
inherency. I also believe in affirm
biblical inherency.
>> Okay. So the Christians that don't
believe in biblical inherency, they
believe that the Bible is true in a
general sense, but not every word of the
Bible is literally true. Those
Christians are those Christians
suffering from some kind of logical
dilemma.
>> Uh yeah, according to the Quran, those
Christians will be out of line and they
will be deviants because they have
nothing to do with the Quran. They have
nothing to do with Islam. These are just
Christians. These are just Christians
who believe in the Bible being generally
true, but they don't literally believe
in every word being true. Are they
suffering a logical this? They have they
don't even know what Islam is. Let's
imagine. Are they suffering from some
kind of logical fallacy or problem or
dilemma?
>> Yes. According to the Quran, they are
>> Yes, they are. So, they are so so they
are logically they're log they have
because you keep saying according to the
Quran. I already said that they have
nothing to do with the Quran. They have
nothing. They have nothing to do with
the Quran. Tell me tell me are they
suffering from some logical problem?
>> Okay, I got you. Yeah, let me at least
talk though. Goodness. So, look. Yes.
according to the Quran, they have an
error. They have a dilemma because
according to the Quran, they're supposed
to believe in every word in their book.
They're supposed to stand on it and
recite it in truth. And if they don't,
if they believe in only parts of their
scripture and reject other words, other
parts of their scripture according to
the Quran, they're disgraced in this
life and they're going to go to hell in
the next. So yes, they have a problem
according to the Quran.
>> According to logic, your name is God
logic, right?
Okay. So, we're talking about logic.
Okay. We're not talking about
we're trying I'm trying to determine
your standards that you apply to Islam
and you apply to the Quran. We want to
we want to understand logic. You're
you're not
>> uh like Quran logic. God logic, right?
Unless you're you believe that God is
Allah, right?
>> I'm shake logic.
>> Maybe you're going to become a Muslim
and your God is going to be Allah and
your channel is going to be changed to
Allah logic soon. But but I'm asking you
according to I'm asking you about logic.
Is it logically incoherent to believe
that the Bible is true in a general
sense without every word of the Bible
being true? Is that logically coherent?
Yes or no?
>> I I'll answer you fully. Yes. According
to the Quran,
>> yes or no? Independent according to
logic. According to logic. Can you
answer Can you answer the question
according to logic?
>> Look, Daniel, this is what you want.
You're not. You're saying according to
the Quran. According to logic.
>> I got you, man. I got you.
>> You don't. You just keep repeating the
same thing to avoid to avoid the fact
that you can't answer a basic question.
You don't know logic, bro. According to
logic, you guys, take a deep breath. I
just be sure we can hear.
>> Yeah. So, let just let me respond and
answer you. What you want to do, Daniel,
and this is what I find with even the
common Muslim. And when I said common
Muslims, because you're you're a
debater, you're like, you know, half a
million subscribers, you're one of the
top guys. Seriously, no faciciousness.
But then you have the common Muslims you
get on TikTok, pop on the streams and
stuff. And a lot of the times these
guys, these Muslims, they wish that they
could debate me or debate any of us away
from Islam as if they were atheists, as
if they're not bound to the criteria and
the standards and the chains of Islam.
But unfortunately, I'm shake logic in
this debate and I'm an original Quran
only Christian. I am going to hold you
to the standard of your book. This what
this is what this debate is about. You
can't escape from your from your
religion. Your religion holds you to
this. So anybody according to your
religion, according to your Quran,
according to your hadith, any Christian,
any Jew who deviates or believes in part
of their scripture is disgraced in this
life and will go to hell in the next. We
read we read the context of the verses.
They're all about legal judgments.
They're all about legal judgments. So
Avery, for example, you do you believe
that user should be prohibited? Do you
believe that adulterers should be
stoned? Do you believe that women should
veil? Because these are all things that
the Bible commands. The Bible is
commanding it. And many Christians have
upheld this in history prior to
modernity. Do you uphold the judgment of
the Bible? Avery, do you do you uphold
it?
>> Excellent question. I uphold all
judgments of the Bible because the Quran
tells me if I don't that I'm a
wrongdoer. I'm rebellious. So guess what
I'm going to do? Because it's not just
illegal judgments. The legal judgments.
Let me finish. It's not just about legal
judgments. It's also about the the the
affirmation of the Quran and Muhammad's
prophethood. Muhammad is supposed to be
mentioned in our scriptures. The Quran
is supposed to be mentioned in our
scriptures. Literally says it in chapter
26 verses uh 192 to 196. It literally
says the Quran itself is mentioned in
our scriptures. 7157. Muhammad is
written in our scriptures. So, it's not
just about legal rulings. We are
supposed to judge according to our
scriptures. And if we do that, we're
supposed to believe in Muhammad as a
prophet because he's mentioned in there.
It's not just about legal rulings. It's
about all of this stuff. Now, the Bible,
where does the Bible say, judge the
truth of Islam based on the Bible? Show
me the verse that says
>> where the Bible says that.
>> No, where the Quran, sorry, where the
Quran says judge the truth of Islam
based on the Bible based on the previous
scripture. 1094
>> where it doesn't say that. It literally
doesn't say that.
>> It literally does.
>> Where does it say judge the truth of
Islam
>> according to the previous scripture?
1094 does not say that.
>> Okay, I got you. Let me let me explain
how it says that.
>> We're not going to go back. See, this is
just a circle.
>> Yeah, you give the same wrong answer
that we've debunked like 30 minutes ago.
>> Wrong and debunked. You you struggle
with this.
>> You you saying that it does uh claim
what it doesn't say. You say we are just
going to read the words. We've read the
words a thousand times by now and
nowhere does it say judge the truth of
Islam. Where does it say judge the truth
of Islam?
>> Okay. Can you read Avery? Like this is
the autism that I'm talking about.
Autism.
>> I got you. So let let me go let me go
ahead and show you what the autism is.
>> Give me 10 give me the verse.
>> You yourself the verse.
>> You got to let me talk.
>> 1094 doesn't say judge the truth of
Islam.
>> Daniel, you got to let me talk. But this
he's just saying the same thing over and
over again. the same question. I give
you
>> so he's just like grandstanding. He
takes 5 minutes to
>> if you want to call him out after like
>> give me another verse. Okay, let's say
1094.
>> Give me give me something else.
>> If you want to call him out after he
allegedly repeats himself and say like,
"Look, he just repeated himself." You
can do that, but I have to let him
respond.
>> Right. So, uh, you you said you want
like give me give you another verse like
get away from 1094. G Avery, please
please give me something else other than
1094 cuz you need you need something
else, bro. Well, look, I'll appeal to
you. You gave me chapter 21:1 17 where
it says, "If you don't know, come to the
people of the reminder." You gave me
1643 that says, "If you don't know, come
to the people of the reminder." So you
keep autism pure autism. Hey, stop stop.
You kept giving me
I don't want to listen to a fiveinut
grandstanding session. Okay, let's just
have two minute sessions. Uh James, cuz
he just wants to just wax poetic now.
>> Yeah, you just want to wax poetic for 5
minutes. We heard this. You You're
repeating yourself. We have a limited
time panicking.
>> I I Hold on. Not because I'm siding with
Daniel, but because I did say earlier
that I was going to put us into
two-minute segments if there's too much
interrupting and you guys
>> you guys have just driven me crazy.
>> Do it.
>> That's fine. So, can I get my two
minutes then?
>> No. You've been talking for two minutes,
>> dude. You've been interrupting me for
two minutes.
>> Yeah, cuz if I don't interrupt you,
you're going to go for 10 minutes.
>> That's not true at all, bro. I talk I
make my points in less than a minute.
Crazy. I just Oh, Zoe, I just love you
guys. Okay,
>> I love I love Daniel and he's fun. He's
>> I just I just You guys have a You have a
chemistry. You know that. Okay. But I
just I just want um
I just want to have uh something that
maybe What if we just did?
>> We could do two minutes.
>> We open to a one minute and then
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm down for that. Whatever
works. Let's do it.
>> One minute. Go ahead.
So my one minute.
>> Yeah, finish up your point. One minute.
Go.
>> Thank you, Daniel. I appreciate it. All
right. So, I'm just tell I'm telling you
how it's saying that it's the judge on
of the Quran on what is true. You
yourself acknowledge that when it's
doubt, doubt is lacking truth,
questioning the truth. The Quran says,
"Here's what you can do to get the
truth. To know that that the Quran is
telling you the truth. Come to us. Go
ask those who've been reading the
scripture before you. That means that
the previous scriptures are the judge on
the truthfulness of the Quran.
See, less than a minute.
Yeah. So, you didn't read from the
verse. You said that means that was the
key phrase. That means like that's your
interpretation. That means the Bible is
the judge of the Quran. That means is
not in the verse. That means that you
said that's your interpretation. I ask
you what does the verse actually say?
Where in the verse does it say judge
Islam and judge the the Quran on the
basis of previous scripture? It doesn't
say that. It doesn't literally say that.
So you're claim that you're only quoting
the Quran and only the words of the
Quran. That's a lie. You're not. You're
saying that means you're giving your
interpretation. You're reading this kind
of autistic reading of the Quran that no
Muslim has ever accepted. No Muslim has
ever read the Quran like this. When we
go to all of the judgment verses that
you've con conveniently skipped over in
Surah Mah, they're all about legal
judgments. Lexalionus, eye for an eye,
stoning, uh the ransom, the the
punishments for criminal acts. That's
what all those verses are about.
Christian apologists say, "No, all of
those verses mean judge all of Islam.
Judge the message of the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him based on our
scriptures." That is extra uh isog
Jesus. That is adding projecting your
Christian apologetics onto the words of
the Quran. I cited hadith. You didn't
address the hadith. I cited Iban Abbass.
You didn't address Iban Abbas. You gave
a partial quote from one of the taps.
Where? By the way,
>> got to go over to
>> Okay. Thank you. Uh Daniel, I I
literally I literally gave you Iban
Abbas. I I didn't just give you an
Abbas. gave you Bkari himself who holds
the position that the previous
scriptures are fully intact textually
and that they are preserved not
corrupted textually but only misrepres
uh misre uh inter misinterpreted and
distorted in their apparent meanings. I
g I gave you that. Now if you want to
say again that Bkari is autistic that
Ibn Abbas is autistic then kal be my
guest all good. Here's your problem.
Your problem is is that when I give you
the verse, you just want to say,
"Nuh-uh. Nuh-uh. That's not going to
help you here. Not against me. That
might work against another Christian."
Not here. According to your Quran, you
Muhammad has to come to this previous
scriptures to know if whether his Quran
is telling the truth. And by the way,
you said this is a Christian
interpretation. Uh that that's not about
other things. Ibek says that this is
talking about Muhammad being mentioned
in their scriptures.
Uh-oh. I guess it's not just about the
laws. Uhoh. I guess it's not just about
one little thing. According to Abadir,
he says that it's about Muhammad being
mentioned in their scriptures and they
know this. This is as clear to them as
their own children. Yet they still rebel
and reject it and ignore it. So is
Ibadir wrong when he says that this is
talking about Muhammad being mentioned
in the previous scriptures? Is he wrong?
You can go ahead and answer that. Yeah.
Where does Ibn Kafir say that uh this
verse means that you have to judge all
of Islam and the truth of the
prophethood of Muhammad peace be upon
him based on the Bible. Where where does
Ib Kafir say that? This is ridiculous.
Like you're again giving your own
interpretation that has no basis in
Quran. It has no basis in taps. You're
just making it up. And you keep bringing
up this point that Bkari records that
the scriptures haven't been corrupted.
What are you talking about? I gave you
the citation of Iban Abbass
recorded in Bkari the hadith or the
narration rather the auth from Iban
Abbass that the previous scriptures have
been corrupted. This is what Iban Abbas
says as recorded in Bkari. So how can
you say that Bkari thinks that this that
the scriptures have not been corrupted?
This is nonsense. I gave you I cited
this in the uh opening statement or the
response period. Um, again, biblical
inherency. Tell me, this is what I I'm
surprised. I'm asking maybe in the chat,
maybe in Avery's chat, someone can
answer this question. Is the Bible
inherent? Can you believe that the Bible
is true in a general sense? And it is
not literally true word by word. Not
every word is literally true. Is that a
logical belief or is that incoherent?
Because if it's incoherent that means
vast uh numbers of Christians are
incoherent. Basically all the Catholics
many of the Protestants as well some of
the church fathers they're also in
incoherent according to that standard of
biblical inherency. Uh god logic
conveniently avoids answering the
question because if he says that it's
illogical if it's illogical to believe
in biblical inherency then that means
there's no Islamic dilemma. And if it is
il illogical or if it is illogical that
means that uh so many Christians are
illogical and are also suffering from a
dilemma. So this is a problem that he
still hasn't addressed either.
All right. So you said what am I talking
about? Watch this. This is from Iben
Cam. It says this talking about the
three positions on the other side.
Here's the third position he gives.
Another party of hadith and fixed
scholars said these changes took place
during its interpretation
and not during the process of its
revelation.
This is the view of Abi Abdullah
Muhammad bin Ishmael
alukari
who said in his hadith collection no one
can corrupt the text
by removing any of Allah's words from
his books but they corrupted it by
misinterpreting it don't do that Abukari
you're on the autistic side don't say
that and then Ibadir in in chapter 3:78
in his tops here he quotes Abu Bakari
given this narration saying that this
comes from Iban Abbas saying that Abbas
says that when they alter and distort
none can alter or add or remove any of
the works from Allah's books they only
distort their apparent meanings.
So according to Bkari and Imabas, the
distortion is not textual. The
distortion is interpreta interpretation.
>> So are they on the autistic side? What I
want to hear you say cuz I asked you.
Are they on the
>> Did you not pay attention to my opening
statement? Like now I realize what your
confusion is. Like you're still stuck on
an hour ago in my opening statement. I
said that there is two different types
of if you saw the slide
versus
means corruption that is through
interpretation whereas means corruption
of the actual text and I said that both
there's both possibilities and I
acknowledge I I will accept that there
are some scholars who said that is
mainly
the interpretive uh corruption. Yeah, I
acknowledge that. But I pointed out in
my opening statement, you must have been
asleep. You must have been not paying
attention, Avery. I'm disappointed in
you. I said that the majority of
scholars say that there is also and
there's both types of
and
so I acknowledge this in the opening
statement. This is not a gotcha. Hey,
Avery. You weren't paying attention when
I was talking to you. Now again, I'm
going to ask for a fifth time. Biblical
inherency. Is it a logical contradiction
to believe that the Bible is generally
true, but not literally every word of
the Bible is true? Yes or no? Can you
answer that, Avery?
Thank you. Uh I I heard everything in
your statement. And you're very careful.
You're very slick, Daniel. Especially
when you panic. You said that you
acknowledge that scholars say mainly. So
there's some scholars that say it's
mainly just by interpretation. That kind
of implies that there's that they they
also believe in a textual corruption. Uh
uh let me do this again. None can
corrupt the text. This is Bkari saying
this. Bukari saying this. Quoting Im
Abbas. None can corrupt the text. Bukari
didn't believe in textual corruption
like you do Daniel. Iban Abbas doesn't
believe in textual corruption like you
do Daniel. They only believe in Tari
Alman right? the one that's about
corruption by interpretation. And now
what's the evidences they give? Oh, also
Al- Razi agrees with this
interpretation. So we got scholars that
say this, right? What's what's their
what's their proof of this? Their proof
is 615. None can change the words of
Allah. They're using the Quran and
they're using the hadith that says that
Muhammad put the the Torah on the
judgment seat. When you're talking
about, oh, it's only about the laws.
It's only about the laws. Guess what
Bkari and Abbas said? No, this is not
just pertaining to the laws. It's
pertaining to the the entirety of the
authority and revelation of the Torah.
>> Yeah. So I read you from Bkari. I read
you from Bkari. Okay. So I don't know
what you're citing in Bkari. I'm citing
Abu Hurra. I read the hadith and I read
the hadith from the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and I read the hadith in
Bkari which says I'll read it again.
This is Iban Abbas recorded in Bkari. Oh
Muslims, how can you ask the people of
the scriptures about anything while your
book which Allah has revealed to your
prophet contains the most recent news
from Allah and is pure and not
distorted? Allah has told you that the
people of the scriptures have changed
some of Allah's books and distorted it
and wrote something with their own
hands.
>> Uhoh.
>> And said this is from Allah so we have a
minor gain for it. Won't the knowledge
that has come to you stop you from
asking them? This is Abbas. I literally
are reading the quote. It's about
changing the book with their hands, what
they write,
not just interpretation. This is
recorded in Bkari. So, okay, maybe there
is another narration that you're uh
mentioning. I don't know what narration
you're referring to, but in this
reference from Bkari that is mentioned
in all the taps, by the way, of 279, the
verse that you cited, they all cite this
statement from Ib Abbass as textual
corruption. This is very clear what Iben
Abbas actually held about the about the
uh corruption of the Bible. Not to
mention the hadith which so far in this
entire debate you haven't even bothered
to address the hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when Omar
came to him with written scripture.
Written scripture and the prophet
sallall alaihi wasallam said don't
believe it. We are at the end of our
open dialogue.